um
you're alive chairman
good evening and welcome to Northwest
planning committee meeting on Wednesday
11th of January
2023 my name is councilor John keys and
I am chairman for this meeting
members we are live we are streaming
this meeting live as well as recording
and by being present in the meeting you
are giving your consent to be recorded
during each item please put your hand up
to indicate if you wish to speak I will
then invite you at the appropriate time
please note that YouTube live stream
sound recording is dependent on the
correct use of the microphones therefore
can I ask you when invited to speak
remember to turn on your microphone and
turn off when finished please reference
page or paragraph number when referring
to the agenda papers and keep your
contributions as clear and concise as
possible
apologies for absence may I have the
apologies for absence please Berner
thank you chairman we've received
apologies for absence from councilors
Morley Stevens and Thompson
thank you all right item three it is
recommended that the minutes of the
meeting held on the 30th of November
2023
found on pages 7 to 10 are approved as a
true accurate record
23 yes it should be apologies it should
be 30 for November 2022 we're a bit
ahead of ourselves yeah
uh found on pages seven to ten are
approved as a true and accurate record I
so moved do I have a secondary for the
motion
saying it if I don't catch this one
decorations of Interest
to declose an existence and nature of a
disciplinary peculiar interest other
registerable interests and non-regible
interests relating to items of business
on the agenda have in regard to
paragraph 9 and appendix B of the code
of conduct for members
members are reminded that they also
require to disclose any such interests
as soon as they become aware should the
need arise through the meeting do I have
any declosure of Interest
catch the song oh yeah thank you Mr
chairman I think I just point out that I
am a
frequent patron of Mr the uh the the
applicant for the second uh Mr Thomas
greggins thank you thank you very much
in pickled onions thank you very much
councilor morning anybody else
I should also declare an interest that
I have bought stuff off of
Tom's Farm Shop over the years so yeah
but it's a non-peculinity interest
foreign
sorry sorry bear we may apologies for
this
application double two stroke zero zero
four nine four
land rear of Hawthorns Braxton Road
Great Braxton we move agenda to item
five found on pages 11 to 22. Mrs Lisa
Greenwood will present the report
good evening good evening
[Music]
yes
Braxton Park Road
the site is located to the south of
brassic Park Road outside of a Divine
second boundary the site message
measures approximately 4 350 square
meters in area
access to your site is via existing
access to Braxton Road one dwelling
Hawthorns is located to the East and
Broadway Farm is located to the West the
site is surrounded on all sides by
owning a country-sized and the character
of the site is rural
planning permission is sought for the
erection of 12 Stables including Tack
and haystor incorporating permissible
rights to connecting to the highway
Network
The Stables measure 38.7 meters wide 7
meters deep and 3.94 meters in height
the planning statement confirms that six
of the Stables will be for a hobby use
and six of the Stables will be for a
commercial use with the potential to
offer Library riding lessons and local
guided Trails or tracks it's
acknowledged that upon validating the
application the local Authority sought
confirmation as to the use of the
Staples and this is reflected in a
change in the description of development
and this was agreed with the applicant
paragraph 5.14 report sets out the
principle of development the current use
of the site is Agricultural and this has
been preferred to a recent appeal and
set out section 5.1.4 The Proposal
however seeks to introduce a part
commercial use
therefore changing the use of the site
this is considered to extend rural
diversification as suggested in the
planning statement submitted to support
the proposal
to fall within the definition of
agriculture The Proposal would have to
keep the horses in the same way as
cattle sheep or pigs I.E to work on the
land
insufficient information has been
submitted to support this change there
is no real explanation of the link or
that it's an ancillary function
and there is no explanation as to the
justifiable or functional need for the
business in this location
in addition to considering consideration
has also been given to the welfare of
the horses and whether the proposed
facilities and land would be compliant
with defra's code of practice
the police States as a general rule each
horse requires approximately 0.5 to 1
hectare of rays of lack of suitable
quality if no supplementary feeding is
provided
electronic statements submitted to
support the proposal states that there's
the potential for the whole city Praise
on a land outside of the red line
boundary
and this measures approximately 28 Acres
however this is outside of the red line
voucher for the site this land therefore
cannot be considered as a reliable and
long-term source of grazing land for
horses as this passive blank could be
sold separately by the owner at a later
date or the arrangement revoked there is
no reasonable way for the local planning
authority to ensure that this land
remains linked to The Stables the gray
sitting out must therefore be within the
red light boundary for the development
site to be considered acceptable
I'll briefly show some photographs but
in summary Incorrect and insufficient
information has been submitted to
support the proposal the applicant is
required to apply for a change of use
and to submit robust evidence to justify
this change
then we need to include things such as
hours of business actual number of
employees
Etc also full details to ensure the
Health and Welfare of the horses is
required and a long-term management plan
the proposal has been found to be
contrary to policies S1 S8 E4 and E5 or
the local development plan and it's
recommended by officers about Planning
Commission is refused
thank you very much so much appreciated
right we have a public participant for
this planning allocation in line with
the public participation scheme I now
invite Mrs Alex Quinn the agent to read
out her submission so if you'd like to
move up
to one of that press the red light
and as soon as you start the timer are
we ready with the timer burner
the timer is all right yes it is thank
you right
thank you chairman the applicants are
Keen Horseman and would like stables
near Hawthorns for hobby use and to
offer Livery and short Pony tricks and
instruction it is low-key and modest in
terms of intensity scale design
appropriate to the rural character
The Stables have policy support from
Malden's policy E4 on Rural
diversification and E5 tourism bullis's
N1 and N3 are also supported through
providing access to a rural activity and
natural assets within the district
these Echo the economic social and
environmental objectives of the nppf
The Stables are ideally placed to
provide good access to Farm rides and
local Bridal ways providing choice and
diversity for the budding equestrian
now objections are raised on grounds of
design character of the building
residential immunity flood risk
biodiversity or trees with no objections
from the public the parish council
highways ecology or environmental health
on the suggested reasons for refusal the
description of development was proposed
by the original case officer and the red
and blue lines were agreed also
the grazing of horses does not require
planning permission but in any event a
condition could Tire permission to the
28-acre field to the rear in the
applicant's ownership or the red line
could be revised to include the land
either way there is considerable grazing
land available within the applicant's
control for the stabled horses
on the second reason for refusal the
requirement for further information on
the demand for horse riding as a tourist
attraction and on horse welfare seems
overly prescriptive
especially when the applicants own
around 50 horses between them and are
well versed in equine care
John Purdy also has commercial
experience of stable ownership with
Livery and lessons
I commend this proposal to you and hope
that you feel able to support it this
evening thank you well done spot on your
time there very well practiced
right members I now invite you to any
questions and comments you have on the
report please
counselor Morley Morgan sorry sorry
uh thank you Mr chairman um I'm
obviously very familiar with this uh
location it's extremely close to where
where I live
um and I recall when the original
building went up some some years back
and I went so I think any cover to say
that some eyebrows were raised at the
planning application for that was passed
but the past it was
and so I think that having a loud
building of that nature to go up a sort
of prestige dwelling in that part of the
world and then to turn around and say
that something which is commensurate
with the use of that baby a stables is
to be refused is quite literally closing
the stable door after the horse is
bolted and I think that that's uh this
sort of application is fully
commensurate with the building as it
currently is it's offering a service I
mean there used to be trail rides in the
area I noticed before which that sadly
fell away uh which I think is uh well
well required in terms of
um tourism and other local uses
um also
um I'm slightly concerned that there's
been sort of a suggestion that
information has not been uh or
incorrectly provided
um it would appear that in fact the
planning officer actually provided the
wording to the applicant
and also I'm a little concerned about
this idea that
um there is need to be a change of use
here
um as far as I'm aware augustment of the
grazing of horses is an agricultural use
so I don't quite I'm not quite sure why
there is a requirement for uh than to
make them an application for a change of
use
and finally I'm not aware of perhaps the
planning officer can put me righteous
when did welfare of horses become a
planning consideration I mean I'm sure
it's something for the rspca to consider
but when is it a planning matter
thank you Mr Jim
anybody else who's right council Mrs
White all right if I come in um if the
land is only going to be used for horses
then technically there should be a
change of use but
um if it's going to be grazed with sheep
and cattle you don't and generally you
feel don't have change of use it's
generally only the buildings that you
need the change of views on and I will
say that I'm a qualified writing
instructor and I was a reserve national
champion at a big national championships
in 2019
um I teach regular Pony Club and I've
also trained Riders who are shortlisted
for um Great Britain teams this year
hopefully they'll be selected so I don't
know what I'm talking about
um the so I have no problem with the
field not being included for me it's all
the buildings and the building's the
perfect size for horses it makes sense
um it's quite often to have half and
half with privately owned horses and
deliveries we personally don't have
liveries but that's Choice
um it's on 28 Acres the minimum
recommended VHS is one acre per horse
and I am a British horse Society
qualified and this is got it over two
acres per horse which is perfectly
adequate and I think the design and
layout works really well with horses and
it looks like it's um a really good
design but what I would say is I I
disagree with the officer's findings on
some of them
um I think this does comply with policy
for Agricultural and also rural
diversification it isn't just
diversification
um and because on the policy Forum page
76 it says the function of the proposed
building stroke activity is directly
linked and ancillary to the existing use
and that number three the building and
activity could not reasonably look out
in existing Town's religiously allocated
employment areas well obviously it
wouldn't and horses are laboring very
labor intensive so there will be a um
uptick in labor and the other point I
had is
um that you know the there is plenty of
land there so actually I'd like to
propose a country view that we approve
this application because for me it is in
line with policy E4 and it will
encourage economic growth in a rural
area because it cannot be cited in a
town or Village or on an industrial site
because it's ruled by Nature so I don't
know if I'll have a second for that
later on I'm not sure enough cancer
Morgan thank you very much
anybody else should all the sure Ward
the same as mine I've called it in fact
I guess uh yeah so I'd like to seek
clarification on
5.1.4 which talks about the Broadfield
fruit farm and I know that I've
eventually on appeal a barn was passed
on that particular site and it was
passed because the applicant was saying
that he would proved that he'd got
agricultural land to use for that site
so are we now saying that the
agricultural land and whether officers
can clarify this for us is no longer
going to be agricultural land and is now
going to be used for horses so surely
yeah we've now got we have got a change
of use in terms of that because the
previous things that we have has gone
through eventually on this site were for
agriculture and were put through as it
was a farm
fully followed you there
um sorry about that can I think so sorry
could just repeat yes on on 5.1.4 okay
so the broad field Fruit Farm
which I went through on appeal said I'm
satisfied that the site was part of
agricultural holding and the F Talent is
in a farming business
so previously the applicant has applied
for a building on this land because it's
for a farming business now that seems to
be changing and therefore surely there
should be a change of use
because previous planning permission was
passed on it being agricultural land
if you
I completely agree with that and that's
the point that the officer was making in
the report so I just wanted to clarify
that that was the case yeah that's
clearly the case thank you children come
back Lisa
uh no I just said I'm happy to respond
on that if but Michael uh said what I
would have said is that um it's not that
we disagree at all that this type of
activity would take place you know in
the countryside
um we felt that the applications just
didn't justify the change of use and it
would be a change of use because this is
agriculture agricultural land and you
are looking to introduce
um a part equestrian use
the application just isn't supported
with enough information
to State you know why why it is
Justified
also with regards to the wording of the
description of the development this was
a validation matter
so um the application hadn't actually
been assessed in full at that point this
was validated by other officers before
it came to me as all applications are
um and therefore we can't get a chance
to actually assess fully what was being
applied for and actually when we kind of
went through the application we realized
what was being applied for was somewhat
different you know that then on the
surface
and it just didn't have the initially
the information to substantiate that
with regard to the grazing um you know
we have an issue that the grazing isn't
provided within the red light boundary
and Michael can possibly confirm us but
we would struggle to tie this in with a
condition
um because we can't place condition on
land outside of the red line boundary we
can only place conditions on on what
what is within the development side
okay
uh I would just collaborate what um my
colleagues said we can't apply a
condition to be able to tie that that
that that land to this site
um again the arguments made in the in
the report that if it's not tied in with
within the Red Lion saying we don't have
any control over it it's up to the
various of the applicant as to what they
would do with the land and that would
long counter to any planning permission
that would be granted the the only the
only way within which
um uh land outside
um the red line site and that if it's a
blue line site owned by the ownership if
it's through a legal agreement and we
don't have a legal agreement as part of
this application that would be the only
mechanism
so in supporting this application or
pass in this application effectively
means it's just the red line site and we
have no control outside of that red line
site and the reason of the animals as
part of the welfare matters is intrinsic
to this application
thank you chairman
anybody else got anything to say before
eyesight Council why I did call this
application and I've got a couple of
things here I think I think the only
other thing we could say is could we
defer it for a legal argument should be
good or not they've already said that
they're happy to um put the land
um within the holding um so could we
could that a possibility to do that
because I don't have any problem with
the Stables themselves
uh just before I say that
um I think what's in the report is that
um it's not that the proposal per se is
not supported or the principle of The
Proposal I would say yeah
um we've had applications like this
before and we've supported applications
like this but it's going through the
proper channels that has to be the
proper legal channels if it's not done
that way it can be open to challenge
yeah particularly with making similar
decisions on other applications and
they're not going through that process
so we do have to be quite clear on the
process
in terms of your suggestion councilor
White
um
it's within members gift to defer the
application
um there potentially could be a
discussion around that I mean I I I mean
it's not just that's not just the only
matter which we've raised here the other
matters are in terms of
um the actual justification again
normally we'd see robust information for
that that hasn't been provided in this
particular case it's not to say that the
argument can't be made it just hasn't
been made in this particular application
so it's more than just us deferring this
and then signing a legal agreement say
we agree to this as well there has to be
some more information I don't doubt that
this can't be provided but it just
hasn't been provided for this and we
need to be quite clear in terms of us
adhering to our particular processes so
I I couldn't just support it be deferred
just for that and for us to come back
with that and again for it to be
supported
thank you chairman if if I might come
back I mean it's certainly for me the
only issue that I can see that's been
raised is the grazing because from a a
horse welfare point of view and a design
point of view
um and The Logical of policy E4 we
developing the countryside I don't
actually have a problem with it so that
I don't know what the other members
think but that's that's my only thing
you know might be possibility but even
then it doesn't have to be purely
um change of views to equestrian if it's
still in part use rugby culture
generally Agriculture and equestrian run
side to side and you'll have horses out
with a cattle and in fact sheep are the
best grazers to put horse horses out
with sheep because they help eat some of
the weeds down so I don't yeah I don't
even have a problem with that but I'll
leave it in the hands the other members
just just briefly I mean I I can see
what you're saying counselor but you
know uh you know the planning's quite
clear on that in that it would involve a
change of use
even if they're closely related thank
you gentlemen
Council Don
yeah thank you I'm not personally
familiar with the site but I'm just
looking at an aerial photograph and it
looks like the field that is being
referred to
and hasn't been
um
under arable agriculture it doesn't look
like it's been cultivated for quite a
long time because there's quite a lot of
scrub trees and things showing on it
um certainly the field
below that has been or is has been under
agriculture so I mean it it looks like a
field that is ripe for for grazing it
does certainly there's been nothing
carried out there it's not been planted
and harvested in
clearly there's no date on it but
um it looks like a relatively modern
photograph but um
overall I don't have a major issue with
it
just on that particular point it's not
the fact that we're you know objecting
to the fact of the land being used for
that purpose it's just that it's not
been included within the red line site
that's just the point that we're making
okay right of um can I go first
counselor
right I've got this is probably Mrs
Fleming is a bit more for this she might
have a
rule payment basic payment schemes now
they've dropped 45 in the last three
years correct and 2027 there will be
none fragrance
right I've got that wrong name I was
looked up and it was 2027. it's a very
poor land we all know that it's gravel
all through there Sandy high input to
farm the land it lends itself to grass
and counselor siddle said 40 years ago
there was grass there were a few fruit
trees growing in it so there has been
grass there now
breeding horses this might be for Mrs
White Mrs Fleming if you've got a
breeding mouth
on grass
you can still claim your rural payments
for agriculture so that must still be
agricultural land if you've got a horse
on it you cannot feed the horses on the
said agricultural land but they oh well
I was from what I've understood you
can't I have to graze but you couldn't
put a bottle of hay out there to feed
them
on breeding mess
so that would technically can still be
agricultural land with horses on it so I
don't think the argument to have it
changed from agricultural to domestic is
right I'll let you come back again Mrs
Watts councilor white even if you want
to go back into the semantics um we're
in the higher level stewardship scheme
and we have one small field uh 16 Acres
which is purely that we use for grazing
horses and that still comes under the
higher level stewardship and we do feed
them hay in the field the only thing
that does happen is if the weather's
really bad we have to bring them in
because they will sort the payments if
the field gets poached so that's
probably why they've left it separate
because you can raise horses 100 on
agricultural land
absolutely it still stays as
agricultural land that you have to look
after it so that's why we would need
Stables is so that when the weather's
bad they come in so they're not poaching
the land right can I Mr Johnson can I go
just to cancel Fleming then yourself
then obviously counts the
Morgan because he's got an offer on the
table right councilor Fleming place
thank you chair
um just looking at the officer's
comments it's there as she seems to be
that they don't have enough information
so my question to Lisa is did she return
to the applicant and ask for the
information that she needed has there
been a sort of backwards and forwards
and I'd like to know whether she's sort
of repeatedly asked for it and it just
hasn't been provided thank you
let me check thank you
God Lisa sorry yeah Mrs Greenwood
acceptable
um
in this case we didn't have the grazing
loud there were lots of different things
lots of information we didn't have
um we wouldn't request this from the
applicant no so we didn't request this
in this instance
okay thank you so clarify for you Mr
Fleming got done
I just wanted to underline that officers
are under no obligation to be going back
to applicants
thank you Jim
Mr Johnson uh yeah I just want again
just going back to that point because I
know there was a little discussion just
now about
um you know agricultural land equestrian
use of horses and this requires time
commission is quite clear the change of
views from agricultural to equestrian
requires planning permission that is the
legal planning position I've just been a
bit concerned the fact that and I say
this respectfully if if we're kind of uh
inventing planning law on in in a
committee chamber you know because that
isn't the case this is the this is the
clear position so any decision on that
basis would actually legally be
ultravirus thank you Mr Johnson all
right councilor Morgan I'll take you all
for the last one yeah just think of it I
mean it's it's obviously I've had a long
day and everything else maybe I'm
getting something wrong but I'm finally
difficult to why we're getting hung up
on this business of change of use if as
far as I'm concerned as far as I was
aware uh like uh you know study
agricultural do grazing of horses is an
agricultural activity and there doesn't
need to be a change of use of that and
the fact that that necessarily all of
the grazing isn't within red line I
don't think is relevant there is as far
as I understand it was within the
original site plan that was put down and
in case I presumed any other change of
uses where you're actually getting the
actual Stables which are being
commercial Stables which are being built
well surely that that the sort of change
of use aspect of that is implicit in the
application itself for the erection of
those Staples so I think we're we're
sort of really what going around in
circles here but arguing the wrong
points I genuinely do
oh okay all right once more Mrs I was
gonna say I would like to make make a
proposal if I can that we
um approve this application because I
say I think we're getting booked down
and stuff I don't think it's necessary
and the building site has got the red
line and and that you can do multiple
use on the field you don't have to
change your views all right Council said
it was a sure Walter son is mine I'll
let you have the final word for yes
thank you so I just want to back up Mr
Johnson says you know we're now we're
Now setting in Preston that anybody with
an agricultural field can go and get
change of use for it was that's the
precedent that this committee is Now
setting and this committee has set those
precedents before and well there you go
right
go on Mr Johnson as well now we've got
an offer on the time yeah I mean I'm I'm
very concerned about this because I
think um any any Google on this matter
will bring up all the various legal
positions on this in terms of the
particular change of views
um it's it's not even a matter
um normally for legal debate in that
sense and there is an undesirable
precedent that would be set on that
basis thank you chairman well I think
yeah right we've um I think the next bit
bear with me but I think the next bit is
I've got an offer on the table we take a
vote on it Mr Johnson which is Jody's
second in offer on councilor Morgan
seconded by councilor White
yeah you sorry that only on same
recommendations could I have a show of
hands please in favor of councilor Watts
proposal
that's three and against Council two so
that is duly carried and burner have you
got the reasons
[Music]
the application be improved the country
to the officer's recommendations
to make it clear if the planning
officers are happy for that to go ahead
that the conditions for approval are
delegation to the planning officers in
consultation with the chairman chairman
uh yes I'm happy to do that yes and
speak award moment both members if
there's any problems
right thank you very much
rights next one is Lawns Farm 29 Plains
Road Great Tottenham Essex the agenda
can be pounded on
item six found on pages 23 to 32 and if
Nicola Ward is it Miss or Mrs Nicholson
Lisa Greenwood sorry apologies sorry
Lisa could you please do the present the
report
of course
of course he's been posted on the
southern side of Plains Road and lies
within within the rural area outside of
any fine set
besides open comprising of maintained
agricultural grassland the site is
neighbor by agricultural fields and a
character's rural the site hosts a small
wooden out building
adjacent to 29 Plains Road The
outbuilding was constructed roughly
between April 2020 or March 2022.
planning permission is sought for the
construction of a stable block tack room
at the feed and machine store
the proposed building is a vanilla shape
and would have a maximum each maximum
height of 6.5 meters within each height
of 3.4 an overall depth of 12.3 meters
and a width of 27.9
meters
the floor plan shows available for
stables and the separate tack room plus
a large feed and Machinery store the
external materials will consist of a
basic brick plinth flu vaccinating the
weatherboard into the walls playing clay
with tiles and Tipper windows and doors
now section five of the officers report
refers to the principle of development
the proposed use of the Stables is
unclear there's been no information
submitted by way of the planning
statement or design and access statement
to provide information with regards to
the domestic or ancillary link to
Lawrence Farm the host dwelling is not
included within the red line boundary of
the site and no information has been
provided as to whether this is an
equestrian or a domestic hobby use
there has also been no information
provided as to where the grazing can be
achieved
whilst it's acknowledged that the site
is within the countryside and it's
considered reasonable to support the
provision of such structures which
aren't outside of the cartilage of the
farm is not considered that the use of
the building would be ancillary to The
Host
if the Stables are to be considered as
commercial no information has been
submitted to
the need for Stables attackers
there is also nothing to suggest that
the Stables could be a tourist facility
the principle of development has
therefore found to be unacceptable
paragraph 5.2 is the report refers to
the design and the impact of the
character of the area
the building would be highly visible
from the surrounding Countryside
by virtue of the fighting and scale and
size and it's considered to have a
detrimental impact on the character and
appearance of the rural area
as can be seen at section
5.4.4 an objection has been received
from the highway Authority
The Proposal is considered to have a
substandard visibility display and the
lack of suitable visibility from the
access for both emerging and approaching
Vehicles would result in an unacceptable
degree of Hazard to all Road you
to the detriment of General Highway
Safety this proposal for Highway
Authority considered was set a precedent
for future development
the proposal has been found to be
contrary to policies S1 S8 E4 E5 T2 and
D1 of the local plan and the guidance in
the framework and it is recommended that
this is refused
thank you very much so much appreciated
right we have a public participate for
this planning application in line with
the public participation fee I would now
like to invite Mr Tony cousins the agent
to read out the submission
you know the
the rules there don't you Mr cousins I
think certainly um two minutes from when
you start your
speech
uh thank you chairman um bang on a
minute Mr cousins
burn up we've got no timer
no just finding it
okay thank you
um the requirement for
design and access statement was removed
some time ago chairman so the applicant
audio agent shouldn't be penalized for
that
um this application for four Stables of
feed room and Tack Store OR tech room
fee store is wholly cited on Long's Farm
it's directly opposite Long's farmhouse
it can clearly and plainly be seen it's
intrinsically linked to Long's Farm
there is no intention of any commercial
use this is for the personal use of the
applicant and for the future diversity
of Long's Farm as a holding
um
The Stables have been designed to the
minimum standards set out by the British
Hall Society so that sets the the
requirement for the bulk and the scale
of the development the tax store and
feed store and the Machinery store
is designed around a functional need for
those particular elements the design is
based on Rural
vernacular propulsions it incorporates
quality vernacular materials and it's
hope that that design would have been
acceptable as a rather attractive rural
building
regarding the second reason for refusal
and and the highways Authority we have
submitted revised drawings which the
highways Authority have accepted could
provide visibility one way so if the
committee aren't minded to approve the
application tonight could I respect it
respectively ask chairman that you
restrict your reason for refusal to the
highways issue which will enable us to
get a speed traffic survey
um completed and we'll resubmit with
that in the future thank you chairman
thank you very much Mr cousins all right
who would like to
who would like to go first
let me just watch
thank you uh I'm not going to repeat
everything I repeated before
um but for me this is um pretty much
it's an even smaller application the
last one it's only four Stables it meets
all the compliances it need to
but actually I do think listening to the
agent that he's made a really good point
and I would fight for this to be
approved I have no problem with design I
have no problem with policy E4 I have no
problem with anything else exactly the
same as the previous application but we
cannot go against highways that for me
is the one sort of Line in the Sand
really so I would propose that we
approve this application in line with
the reasons for approval with the
previous application
um
waiting on and then we put that the only
reason for a fuse or down as the highway
issues obviously if it's the highway
issues we can't argue with that like we
didn't last month with the house that
was in Clarks we we have to respect
highways so
um my proposal is that we refuse the
application but only on the highways
issue because I think it otherwise it's
policy compliant thank you
councilor Daryl majority come back but I
I concur with councilor white the only
slight issue with Essex County highways
at the moment is that they're unable to
conduct any speed surveys until April
um so whether that's going to fit in
with the applicant or not
I I don't know it's just a it's a it's a
comment that the applicant needs to be
aware of that
that there is no budget for Speed
surveys we're four month waiting in your
phone three and a half months
right Council serial that's your award
same as mine uh
yeah
so
um in terms of the this particular
application uh it's not just four
Stables if you if you if we could look
at the proposed floor plan
um on the presentation Lucia could have
the proposed floor plan so it's not just
four stable it's also massive uh room
that we're not quite sure what it's
going to be used for
um yeah it's saying in terms of that
it's not intrinsically linked to the
farm
um it's across the road so there's not
an intrinsic Link Between The Farmhouse
and this this particular uh stable block
um in terms of these things
I think the design is good but it's too
big you know for this particular site
and for this particular location and for
that field it is far too big
so I'm using my local knowledge in terms
of this and it is much much too big for
that particular site
and therefore we would we can't just
refuse it on the on the the transport
side the highway side of things we have
to we have to refuse it on the scale of
this it's not the design of it it's the
scale of this property and this
development and that's the key issue
yeah it's it's it would have a big
impact on the side of the road where
there really there's only one house and
a small Stables further up the road so
this would have a really big change in
terms of the character and the design
and and the impact on that raw
relocation so we've we've got to look at
it you know in terms of that aspect as
well so I would say that we need to
refuse it in terms of its scale as well
it's a proposal you're putting
no second
uh
right
um councilor white you asked to come
back yes uh thank you Mr chairman
um yeah I'd just like to comment on the
design I mean as you know I keep horses
my I'm rather large so my horses are a
lot rather large and my stables at home
I'm not sure what the exact meterage is
the minimum legal requirement for a
single in the UK and we're talking for
Little Ponies here is 12 feet by 12 feet
my horses are all around about 17 to 18
hands
um which is probably about their way
taller than me so I'd say probably about
six foot two six foot four ish in height
they're bigger than that in length I
don't know what the length is
um and my seat belts at home are 14 feet
by 18 feet and we have just got planning
permission we've got plenty of companies
go for a barn and the Stables inside
that are going to be exactly that size
also with the Machinery store
um a horse in the winter will eat a
minimum of one bale of hay a day that
means each horse will have to have seven
bales of hay a week if you times that by
four that's quite a lot of bales of hay
I'm not going to do the math tonight
because I'm bound to be wrong
um so you need that in the Machinery
store and if anybody's kept horses I can
tell you the amount of stuff they have
to have is unreal the other thing is
um horse trailers tend to be very
popular for theft and I would imagine
looking in that Barn you will have hay
in store in it and then you'll have the
horse trailer parked in front so it
doesn't get stolen I mean theft of horse
trailers no matter how well they're
tracked I mean for me I don't understand
why we're saying it's a really big
building it looks like a really
functional building and and I'd love to
keep my horses in there so I have no
problem with the size I mean I've
already made a motion which was seconded
and we'll have to see what happens
um with that and see what members say
but I've got no problem with design
whatsoever
if you want to come back Council Johnson
or do you want me to go to Mr Council
first
sorry uh bear with me bear with me okay
yeah yeah
uh yeah in terms of what councilor white
has just said she's just given every
single reason why we should refuse this
because in in terms of the the plot I'm
sure cancel it's got lots of land this
isn't a lot of land it's a small field
and and all those things in terms of all
those things that are needed are
unnecessary on this site yeah that
that's the crucial thing it's it's too
big for this particular location
um and it's if you look at the plan it
is it is not on the same site as the
farm it is opposite so it's not
intrinsically linked either it's you
know so again that's the reason why
we've got to refuse something on this
scale oh thank you Council Johnson do
you want to come back
Mr Johnson as you can see it might
actually get me moving to Malden now
um yeah well actually I wanted to concur
really with the with the points made by
councilor siddle the the functional link
to the dwelling if I can ask Ms
Greenwood just to bring up the plan
um just showing the relationship between
the site and dwelling house
yeah uh
if we can have the one yeah that's it
yeah
um again it's similar to some of the
issues that were raised
um with the previous scheme
um
the red line is just around this site
which is across the road and it is
separated the Blue Line only identifies
that
um
you know the house is in the ownership
in planning terms it would be a separate
planning unit which is being created
here
um that in itself can cause issues
there's no functional link we can't uh
condition that it would be tied in
there's nothing we can do in that
particular sense so again that's that
that raises concern in terms of of how
that land can be used in the future
separate from the dwelling house
particularly for the purpose in which
it's it's it's so it's actually proposed
so significant concerns are arranged
there again the justification arguments
have not have not been provided
um and
um in terms of the design there's
there's two parts to this building I
mean we have and hopefully Miss Mrs
Greenwood can uh can can confer here in
terms of the height of the of the sort
of shorter perpendicular bit the larger
bit if I if I recall I think it was
seven point 0.5 meters if I seem to
recall am I crazy I was actually I was
gonna
be very different to other applications
that we've seen four Stables it's almost
double height
and there are high windows I think
this is
yeah I mean I mean I'm I'm more used to
seeing the stable similar to the height
of the of the long longitudinal section
um I I could more appreciate an argument
in terms of its acceptability more
appreciate not saying I accept but more
appreciate an argument if we were just
dealing with that with that element of
it which is more commensurate to what
we're used to that perpendicular larger
bit is is out of scale and I think the
photo showed the nature of the area the
openness of the area
um counter still pointed to one other
dwelling I imagine there probably would
have been one other but somewhere not in
this particular vicinity and not even
within the immediate visitors of this
site
um so these are the reasons for our
particular concerns with this
application
um similar but also separate issues to
the previous application that that was
raised thank you chairman
hello Mr Johnson
right well I'll I'll catch my Morgan
uh yes thank you well obviously once I
take cancer settles point and I also
understand the the officers are saying
and I noted in the report it states that
this could cause substantial harm to the
vicinity I have to say these are
ultimately a subjective judgments and
um I they're persuaded by Council
White's point that this is a functional
building designed specifically for its
purpose and therefore
um I I see no reason why it shouldn't be
in there but having said that as I've
already seconded cancel the whites
promotion I do believe that the highways
issue does have to be resolved thank you
thank you as anybody else something
inside right well I've got two offers on
the table we've got counselor whites and
councilor siddles I'll go with councilor
whites first and then cancer soodles
right and those in favor for councilor
whites to put it for a highway report
no we have to do some counselor siddles
as well do we know well effectively that
would be the case yeah uh this murder
can provide some clarification on that
succeeds
if it succeeds
okay just for clarity yeah right yeah
yeah can we just also clarify it
it's up to refusal in the first instance
yes and we're saying that what we want
to do it because the wife which is
proposal is saying that it's refused on
the basis of the highways issue alone
correct correct
okay sensible
right those Inc favor of Council of
wipes motion please raise your hand
right that's three those against
two
so that's councilor whites
proposal passed
have a look
is that right
that's what I've done it all yes right
thank you very much Seth right let's
crack on with the next one right next
one
plan application double two stroke
double zero nine three one nine Cherry
Blossom Lane cold Norton we move to
agenda seven found on pages 33 to 48 and
Lisa Greenwood could you please present
the reports
all right
thank you
the application currently comprises of
grassland
immediately adjacent to the south of the
site is number seven Cherry Blossom Lane
editing touch Bungalow to the north of
the site is Garland known as poplars
Planning Commission is thought to
construct a detached buckler with
Associated office street parking and
community space
dwelling would be located along the
northern edge of the site and it would
have a similar orientation to The
Bungalow to the South
it will measure 17.6 meters in depth 8.5
meters in width at 5 .1 meters to the
beach
paragraph 3.1.5 sets out the background
to the application
this application follows a previous
application for a similar proposal that
was approved in 2017 for the
construction of a detached bungalow
they've swallowed a previous appeal
which was initially refused but then
allowed to appeal in 2014.
the current application seeks to amend
the design of the Bungalow very very
slightly it would be modestly larger in
size and would
have an alternative roof design the
layout would be similar to what has
already been approved it mustn't be
noted that the previous application was
approved over three years ago and as the
development has not been commenced the
commission
now expired
the clinic history for the site is
therefore a material consideration
whilst the site is outside of the
settlement called Norton
and that's the principle the developing
its contrary to the policies in the
development plan which lead to direct
new development to established
settlements the development since about
it regards the settlement boundary and
the previous inspectors comments the
principle has been found to be
acceptable it's acceptable in terms of
put on the area there have been no
technical or neighborhood
of deceived and it's therefore
recommended that planning permission is
granted
right thank you very much Lisa there are
no public participants in this
application so um
second date
all right councilor white please first
before we go there thank you I mean I I
love these little um developments that
are on the edge of boundaries and in
villages um I've got no problem I do
however there's nothing on highways the
parish council had just spent a hundred
thousand pounds
um tarmacking the road
um which when it was pretty surprised
was a a rough track and I've gone
through everything and I'm a bit
disappointed that Mr Penny didn't try
and work with the parish [ __ ]
beforehand I'm a bit disappointed
there's nothing in the paperwork about
any harm that could be done to the road
this brand new road which was only
finished literally a few weeks ago
um and oh it might be a couple months
ago now um and I I just wondered if
there was any way we could defer it to
um get some additions and assurances
made to what's going to happen with this
new road and potentially is there any
way of doing a sexual memo six so that
they add an area on this made-up Road
only because all the lorries going over
the lip of this brand new road
construction glories I'm worried that
it's going to damage it so
I'm sort of saying yep I'm happy with it
I've not got a problem with it but I'm
concerned we don't have enough
information on looking after this road I
know it's a private road but it is still
pertinent
um for me so that that was that was my
view on it
Council Fleming
thank you chair I just wanted
um Michael and Lisa's uh comments on
that the the issue of the new road
surface uh whether that uh it's it's I
know it's a private road
um it could have an informative be put
on there
oh
Mr Johnson uh
and well did Lisa want to say something
I don't Lisa would you like to comment
first
um
yeah
thank you and I just wanted to write it
in planning terms I mean it's outside of
the of the application site
um those matters I I do appreciate that
I've read the comments
yeah but there's nothing we can actually
do about it nothing that would legally
you know fall with it within our
planning remake
oh don't miss Johnson uh councilman
just to say that if there's a private
road there's usually a scheme or some
sort of system up and running for me for
it to repair and maintenance that's part
of the reasons
[Music]
Fleming would you like to come back
again please thank you chair now that
we've squared away that one I just
wanted to ask about uh EV charging
points I just had a look at the
conditions I didn't see anything there
so standard okay I saw that you'd put in
bike uh something for bikes
um and what about rain water collection
have you got anything covering that
I'm thinking water butts
um it's not the sort of thing we would
normally
ask for as a conditioner I don't think
it would meet the test okay well my
personal view is though it should be on
known free no I I appreciate it
just to clarify the EV charging point is
there because I didn't see it listed in
the conditions
yeah because it's not actually in the
list of conditions so you can add that
right okay brilliant thank you
right are they offer on a table from Mr
White wasn't second so and could we all
have a Shot Hands good recommendation
right that's your name is right
any other business there are none
closure of the meeting menu members
thank you for your contribution this
evening I now draw the meeting to close
at
8 27th
as this meeting is now closed member
advised not to enter any further
decision discussion and please leave the
chamber promptly
thank you very much and sorry if I
referred